social media is your window on the world
right now and you'll probably already
know our next guests the marsh family
who went viral were their adaptation of
a late news classics with their very own
lock down lyrics let's have a listen
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're joining us now Ben and Daniel
Marshall and with Alfie Thomas Ella and
Tess all in very fine voice there good
afternoon to you and Ben talk to me
about how this idea came about because
you've used these lyrics to basically
then the frustration that families up
and down the country are feeling having
to live work and home school is such
close proximity yeah that's right we've
been homeschooling for just over a week
and we've been through the sort of first
phase of shock to the system and
everyone's still having adrenalin
getting used to it felt a bit like a
school holiday or a bank holiday or
something except because of the external
environment so we combination of kind of
frightening but it also feeling like a
weekend at the same time and then as the
days went on in the week people got
tired people got bored work was coming
in from schools or not coming in from
schools there's an experience that we
knew everyone else was having too so it
made sense to kind of stick it down and
put it in a song which is something
we've always done and what Danielle is a
very creative way of letting out your
family's frustrations and we were kind
to you as a family we didn't broadcast
the argument which takes place before
you get into the song because there
wasn't even a bit of frustration then
about who did what who said what how did
he come together as a family to divide
up the parts and the lyrics to peace and
quiet and he came back and said I've put
some lyrics down to a song that we'd
always talked about maybe doing
something with and just for fun and
previously we'd had some discussions the
boys didn't really want to turn to play
Marius because that was a bit of a
romantic part but when Ben said oh I've
changed the lyrics to this and it it
just fell into place really and everyone
just had a bit of a go of it on Saturday
by Sunday afternoon we said oh well
let's have a go and that was it really
well I loved it even your grandparents
got a mention because I know you as a
family can't go and see your
grandparents at the moment like so many
of us and this is a question for ask
Alfie and Thomas you're keeping our
spirits up with these videos how are you
keeping your spirits up there at home
with your sisters and your parents um
well I think just the most important is
just trying to find new things that
you're able to do so for instance
playing a board game because we've got
plenty of board games that we hadn't had
an opportunity to play as a family
because they'd just been collecting dust
on a shelf and we've taken them down and
we've learnt the rules to them and so
yeah just creativity and trying to just
make sure that you have something to do
at all times and in our case music
largely
because actually even if you're not a
great musician or you've never done it
before
musics probably a really good way of
just sort of letting out your stress
because it's really fun to do and we
still had a bit of fun with it and it
went viral
so you know you never know well well I
love it well done I mean I myself could
become a dab hand you know I'll confine
my singing singing in the shower I'm not
gonna broadcast that's a nation because
I'm not as good as you and the master
family thank you so much and Renee you
got some more videos coming our way so
we look forward to those thanks a lot
for joining us